será el fin del conflicto la Corte
Internacional de Justicia negó la
petición que hizo Nicaragua en 2013 para
extender su plataforma continental Más
allá de las doscientas millas náuticas y
que interfería con la zona económica de
Colombia
la corte ha concluido que bajo la ley
internacional el derecho de los estados
a una placa continental Más allá de las
200 millas náuticas desde la línea base
no se debe extender Más allá de las 200
millas desde la línea base de otros
estados lo siguiente considerando estos
puntos técnicos y científicos Nicaragua
no tiene derecho a una placa continental
extendida a 200 millas náuticas desde la
línea base de la costa de Colombia
el conflicto limítrofe entre ambos
países se remonta el siglo pasado pero
en 2001 Nicaragua realizó la primera de
tres demandas ante la haya pedía la
soberanía sobre las islas de San Andrés
Providencia y Santa Catalina en ese
momento la corte otorgó la soberanía de
esas Islas a Colombia pero obligó a
ceder casi 75 mil kilómetros cuadrados
del Mar Caribe al país centroamericano
luego Managua denunció a Bogotá por
realizar actividades de pesca y
patrullaje en las aguas que la corte
recién le había otorgado y ganó el fallo
en el tercer caso sentenciado hoy
Nicaragua reclamaba que se definiera los
límites Más allá de las 200 millas
náuticas sobre la base de la plataforma
continental que se extiende desde su
territorio pero la corte falló a favor
de Colombia y reafirmó los límites que
había definido en 2012 sobre una zona
con ricas reservas de gas y petróleo
Gran Victoria para Colombia en la haya
la Corte Internacional de Justicia no
accedió a las pretensiones de Nicaragua
sobre expandir su plataforma continental
esperamos con este fallo cerrar la
controversia limítrofe y abocarnos a
llevar desarrollo sostenible a nuestro
archipiélago el daño que le han hecho a
Nicaragua ahora el fin de años de
controversia dependerá de la reacción de
Managua cuyo gobierno uno se pronuncia
al respecto la corte aclaró que la
aplicación de la sentencia depende única
y exclusivamente de la buena voluntad de
los estados